I think we're now ready to
tackle the big picture and
what has our government
officials so
worried right now.
So what I've done is, I've just
drawn the balance sheets
for a bunch of banks.
Obviously, this is simplified.
And I made all of their balance
sheets look the same.
All of these banks, each of
these kind of represents the
balance sheet of a bank.
And just to explain it, the
left-hand side of this balance
sheet, so this column right
here-- and maybe I can, at
least for the first bank,
mark it a little bit.
So what I'm squaring off
in magenta, that's the
assets of that bank.
What I'm squaring off
in blue, that's the
liabilities of the bank.
And what I wrote here is, it has
$4 billion of liabilities.
Its assets, I divided it between
$3 billion of other
assets and $2 billion of CDOs.
Because we want to focus on the
CDOs, because that's the
crux of everything
that's going on.
And we have $5 billion in
assets, $4 billion of
liabilities, so you have
$1 billion in equity.
So that's what's left there.
So this is just another visual
representation that
liabilities plus equity
is equal to assets.
Or assets minus liabilities
is equal to equity.
And I've just copied and pasted
this one balance sheet
a bunch of times.
I don't know whether we're
going to use all those.
But let's just assume, for
simplicity, that a ton of
banks in the system have this
identical balance sheet.
Obviously, they don't have an
But all of their balance sheets
might have kind of
similar properties.
This isn't always the case,
different banks have different
exposures to CDOs.
Some of them have a lot, some
of them have a little bit.
Some of them are valuing
them more
conservatively than others.
But just for the sake of
simplicity, I've just made all
the banks in the situation where
the book value of the
CDOs that they have on their
balance sheets is the larger
than their equity value.
And I did that for a reason.
Because it leads to the issue
of, are these banks facing
just a liquidity issue
or are they facing
just a solvency issue?
If you believe that these are
worth $3 billion, these
assets, these liabilities are
worth $4 billion, then the
crux of whether it's a liquidity
or a solvency issue
all falls down as to whether
these are worth
$2 billion or not.
For example, if these are worth
$2 billion, then you
have $1 billion of equity.
If these are worth $1.5 billion,
well maybe they're
being a little optimistic here,
but you'll still have
$0.5 billion of equity.
So you're still solvent.
And in that situation, in
theory, one is just if they
don't have the cash when some of
their debt comes due, they
should just be able to
borrow some money and
get past that hurdle.
And then in the future maybe
sell their assets and still
have positive equity.
However, if the true value of
those CDOs, and this is kind
of a philosophical question,
what's the
true value of anything?
And the best thing that we as
humans have been to be able to
come up with is a market.
The market value tends to be the
best representation of the
true value of something.
Let's say the true value of this
is $1 billion or less,
then we have a situation.
For example, if these are worth
nothing, then we only
have $3 billion of assets, $4
billion of liabilities, we
have negative equity.
This company is worth nothing.
And to lend this bank or this
company any money would just
be throwing good money
after bad.
Because that money is just going
to go into a black hole.
Because one of the people who
this company owes money to is
probably not going to
see their money.
And if you are the most junior
person lending the money--
which means that when all the
money is distributed if they
go into bankruptcy, you're the
last person to see the money--
then you're just throwing
good money after bad.
So that's the issue.
But I want you to see
the big picture now.
Because if it was just an
issue with one bank it
wouldn't be a big deal.
If it was just Bear Stearns
or if it was just Lehman
Brothers, not a big
deal, let the
greedy bankers go bankrupt.
And they probably are doing
just fine with the bonuses
they've collected after sourcing
these CDOs for the
past eight years or five
years or however long.
But what I want to show you in
this video is what people are
talking about when they
say systemic risk.
So these $4 billion in
liabilities, these are loans,
maybe from other banks.
In fact, probably from
other banks.
And those loans from other
banks, those are assets of
other banks.
For example, let's say this
is Bank A, this is Bank B.
Maybe a billion of these
are a loan from bank B.
And if this is a loan from Bank
B, Bank B would have an
asset called loan to Bank A.
On Bank B's balance sheet
we're calling this a
loan to Bank A.
This is one of its assets.
And then one of its liabilities
will be a loan
from Bank B.
So how can I say this?
They took this money and
they gave it to B.
I'm sorry, B had money, gave it
to A in the form of a loan.
And so that cash
ended up here.
And they got an asset called
loan to Bank A.
And this is a liability,
loan from Bank B.
And they might have taken that
money and they might have lent
it to Bank C down here.
I think you're starting to see
how this gets pretty hairy
very fast. So let's say that
Bank A, one of its $3 billion
in assets, is a loan
to Bank C.
And so on Bank C's balance
sheet, it'll say
loan from Bank A.
Or so we owe A $1 billion.
And A says, C owes me $1
billion, and that's all fine.
And then you see that oh,
we owe B $1 billion.
And then we could
keep doing this.
Or I could just even make this
into a circle already.
So maybe Bank B has some money
that it owes to someone else.
And let's say that someone else,
just for fun, just to
make this interesting-- I think
you can extrapolate and
think about how this gets
complicated very fast. Bank B
has borrowed money
from Bank C.
So Bank C will have an asset
here that says, no I lent
money to Bank B.
Fair enough.
OK, so now we're in an
interesting situation.
Let's say this loan, the
loan from Bank B to
Bank A comes due.
And we've studied this
multiple times.
And let's say for whatever
reason, all of these other
loans, they're not liquid.
They're not due yet.
So Bank A can't get rid
of these loans.
So let's say this comes due,
this is $4 billion.
They can't sell any of this.
So Bank A has to come up with $1
billion somehow for Bank B.
So that's the situation
we're dealing with.
I'm just going to say
that they can't sell
any of these assets.
So it all comes down
to the CDOs.
So there's a couple
of issues here.
If you think it is just an issue
of illiquidity, if these
are $2 billion of assets,
they're really worth $2
billion, but Bank A just
can't sell them.
Because either there's
quote-unquote
nobody willing to buy.
Although, I would argue if
no-one is willing to buy
something, then its true
value is probably zero.
But let's just say Bank A says
no-one is willing to buy,
we're just illiquid, this is
really worth $2 billion.
So one situation is they could
get a loan from someone.
Maybe the Fed would be willing
to take this as collateral.
So they would give this as
collateral to the Fed.
Maybe the Fed will give them
a billion dollar loan.
And then they can use
that to pay Bank B.
Let's say that's off the table
because this is just smelly
enough collateral that not even
the Fed, which we now
realize is willing to do
anything to support the
markets, not even the Fed is
willing to give them a loan.
Or enough of a loan to
pay off that loan.
The other situation is maybe
they can get an equity
infusion from a sovereign
wealth fund.
And we covered that a couple
of videos ago.
Where the sovereign
wealth fund will
essentially inject some cash.
It'll dilute the shares and then
you know maybe we had 500
million shares before.
Now we'll have 2
billion shares.
So the sovereign wealth fund
will take over roughly 80% of
the company.
And in exchange for 80% of the
company, would give maybe $2
billion and then you could use
that to pay off this loan.
But let's say that that's not
on the table anymore either.
Because the sovereign
wealth funds have
gotten burned so much.
So what happens?
Well we learned what happens.
If you can't get a loan, a new
loan, to replace this loan, or
if you can't get an equity
infusion from kind of a
greater fool, what happens?
You go into bankruptcy.
And this is what happened
to Lehman Brothers.
Lehman Brothers went
into bankruptcy.
No sovereign wealth fund, no one
else bought the company.
And I should probably
do another
video on that scenario.
And they couldn't get a loan.
So they went bankrupt.
I should call this Company
L actually.
But I'll call it Company
A for now.
Because I don't want
to impugn anyone.
I actually don't think Lehman
was any worse or better than
any of the other players here.
So when they go into bankruptcy,
something very
interesting happens.
Now, Bank B, they were already
worried about these CDOs.
These CDOs were already
an issue.
And they were probably thinking,
boy when when Loan C
comes due, I'm going
to be in trouble.
Or when Loan D, or F, or
whatever, I'm going to be in
trouble because I'm going to be
in that situation that I'm
essentially forcing Bank
A into right now.
But now I have a new problem.
This loan to Bank A isn't
getting paid off.
And who knows?
Bank A is going to go
into bankruptcy.
Maybe in bankruptcy we realize
that these are worth nothing.
And if those are worth nothing,
then maybe I'm very
junior in seniority in terms of
where my loan is and maybe
I get nothing.
Or I get a few pennies
on the dollar here.
So maybe I thought this was $1
billion and I have to write
this down to $0.5 billion.
So now I have two problems. I
have this and I have this.
And once again, this is
a non liquid loan.
Bank A is in bankruptcy.
And if I wanted to somehow get
the value of this I have to
wait for all of Bank A's assets
to go into liquidation.
And then whatever assets I get
I would have to sell it.
So this is kind of
a frozen asset.
So once again, I'm stuck holding
this non liquid asset.
So now I have this non liquid
asset that's probably not
worth what I thought it was,
which was a loan to A.
Then I also have these CDOs.
And now, God forbid, let's
say that I had another
loan to Bank D.
And now let's say Bank
D goes bankrupt.
And then I have another
loan that's bad on
top of these CDOs.
But the CDOs were the
crux of the issue.
That's what caused
the situation.
If Bank A could have only sold
this CDO for $2 billion, it
wouldn't have caused this
chain reaction.
And Lehman Brothers really was
the thing that catalyzed this
whole chain of events.
And then you can imagine now
Bank C is worried because now
Bank B has all of these illiquid
assets on top of
these CDOs and it starts
to look bad.
And you can imagine, now it's
even less likely that when a
bank, let's say that Bank D is
the next one to go into a dire
situation, it's even less likely
that Bank D can get a
loan from a third bank.
Because all the banks are
getting scared now.
All the banks are saying,
I'm not going to
loan money to anyone.
If I can get any cash from
anybody I'm just
going to keep it.
So that when it's my turn, when
the market starts looking
at me, I at least have
a little cash.
So everyone is frozen.
Everyone wants to collect their
loans from everyone else
and no one wants to give
loans to anybody else.
So that's the situation
we're in.
And that's the difficulty
that the Fed is
somehow trying to unwind.
And I realized I'm out
of time again.
I will confront that issue
in the next video.